are you guys doing you're doing good
well today's your lucky day cuz I'm mark
wahlberg and there's two types of movies
in this world movies i was in and movies
i should have it in and today we're
gonna take those movies i should have
been in and fix their mistake let's do
this i do with me I wouldn't look with
me okay hard hey be quiet down there it
puts a tanning lotion in the basket or
it gets the carbs again that's enough
that's enough look if you have a protein
shake and and I have a protein shake and
I have a straw okay and my straw goes
all the way all the way past dorchester
past that Parker I beat up Kennedy that
one time and I know you saw that and I
drink it up I drink it here don't you
cry on my sweater
they stole it from us they stole our
precious no sneaky Hobbit so not master
master would go to bat for me I love mr.
you don't have any friends nobody likes
you we only had precious why would you
say that to me I'm not listening I'm not
listening you're a liar sitting and you
don't work out enough leave now and
never come back you can think you better
than get your [ __ ] get the god of here
take 95 south and don't ever come back
you don't tell me where to go this I'm
going to Wahlburgers
you